[موسيقى]
اللي اخذ اشكال وحشيه في المجتمع العراقي
سببها ايضا وهذا يعني ارتفع بدرجه كبيره
زواج القصه
كبير بالعمر ياخذ له طفله كبيره بالعمر
تاخذ لها شاب اصغر من عندها فما يتفاهمون
والاكبر والاسوا اذا كانوا اثنينهم اطفال
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
معاناه استمرت خمس سنوات عندي اثنين اطفال
الاسباب اللي دفعتني اطلق ان هو ما كان
يصرف على البيت انسان قاعد يشتغل يوم
وقاعد عشره ايام وكان يضربني وياذيني اي
حقوق كان ما مسويها الي كحقوق زوجيه
ويحاربني حاليا كل ما اطلب النفقه
بالقانون وبالشرع احد من عائلتي يروح
لبيتهم يطلب نفقه يحاربني ويبتزلي
بالاطفال
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
معكم معالجات قانونيه لهذا العنف الاسري
يتم التعامل وياه الموضوع من يعني من قبل
جهات حكوميه ومن قبل منظمات مجتمع مدني
لكن نفتقر الى وجود قانون يعالج هذا العنف
الاسري
[موسيقى]